hello everyone here we have a remarkable
game where a Rashid Najma Dino takes us
on a journey through a horrifying maze
of variations that probably only him and
Michael tell could work their way around
the game was played in 1954 it was
played in a tournament in Bucharest and
he's playing the international master
from Italy and Rico Polly and although
Russian asthma Dino didn't manage to win
this tournament he got second place only
half a point against the Viktor Korchnoi
himself but as always it was a Rashid
about tuition is Medina who won the
brilliancy prize for the most beautiful
game played so let's see this game and I
couldn't find a younger photo of mr.
Paulie but it doesn't really matter
because the guy won italian Chess
Championship at the age of 60 so you
know quite a strong player rush it opens
with E 4 we have C 5 the Sicilian
defence Knight to f3 d6 d4 C capture son
d4 Knight captures and Knight to f6
we have Knight to c3 and a6 the knight
of variation Bishop to g5 we have D 6
and here as always say you can always go
f4 this is the main line today but in
those days Queen to f3 was a very
regularly played move in tournaments one
of my favorite games sorry one of my
favorite games featuring Queen to f3 is
the game I always mention a bronsted
versus night or I will put a link to
that game in the description as well so
do check it out it's quite quite an
educational game and you can really you
can really learn a lot from Bronstein in
that game in this game Rasheed also went
for Queen to f3 and here we have Queen
to East Bishop to e7 rushing to castles
Queen side and here quintus e7 was
played there's a famous trap in this
position if black decides to play Bishop
to d7 first maybe some of your opponents
will do this
maybe they'll decide to Castle later
with the idea that they want to go
Knight to c6 and if you capture they
want to recapture with the bishop but
the Bishop to d7 is actually
a terrible blunder because here white
simply pushes a 5 and after you capture
it he captures now you have this
crushing move which Knight captures on
e6 threatening the Queen threatening the
g7 bond so the bishop record of course
is pinned if you capture with the bishop
then the rook captures Queen so we have
to capture with the F pawn and after
pawn captures now you have bezel
captures and f6 Bishop captures and
Queen captures on b7 threatening to
capture the rockin a8 after Knight to c6
now the Queen is preventing this but now
comes rock captures on b7 and white is
winning this game again you're
threatening the Queen you're threatening
the night Queen has to capture the rook
and after Queen captures Queen captures
rook on a8 this is what check bishop
blocks and now simply Queen captures on
a6 Europe two pawns and the blacks
position is completely busted your pawn
structure is I mean it's practically
perfect you can make whatever you want
from it so it's a completely winning
game for white but in the game of course
Enrico Polly doesn't go for this Bishop
to d7 but you should remember it if
you're a Queen f3 player and maybe your
opponent plays it so here quintus e7 was
played rock to g1 rashid immediately
prepares his pawn pushing radius Bishop
to d7 and now g4 we have Knight to c6
Bishop to e3 h6 now and h4 r up the c8 g
5 immediately
we have H captures G captures and Knight
to e5 first attacking the Queen on f3
any on f3
Queen to g2 and here we have Knight the
g8 so as you can see that night is very
displaced there on g8 and Rashid
immediately takes advantage of this he
pushes f4 Knight goes to c4
now we have Bishop captures Queen
captures and f5 here here b5 is played
now comes King to be one with the idea
that this night will want to move at one
point and if the king will be an c1 the
Queen captures on C 2 will be checkmate
after you know the position explodes so
King to be one we have before here
attacking the knight and c3 and this is
the position you really want to you know
enjoy this is the kind of position that
Rashid was the best in and this is why
only him and probably make Hotel could
could play a game like this so pause the
video here and try to find an edge
Menino's idea here it's I mean don't try
to calculate everything because it's
really impossible just you know try to
try to find the first move and the idea
what black will reply so I will give it
a couple of seconds for you to decide as
usual okay for those of you who found it
very nice you're you're an excellent
player and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show in this position
a Rashid give a tuition is me Dean of
played g6 and what's the idea behind g6
well first of all it creates a complete
mess of a position you have to take a
lot of things into consideration as
black new capture on c3 do you capture
on f5 new capture on g6 do you push f6
new push a 5 so there's like an entire
sea of options here I'm not gonna go
into F capture some g6 because this
simply allows Queen captures on g6 and
white simply gains too much here but
let's try some ideas like f6 if you play
f6 this doesn't help help black if f6
then you get F captures on e6 and after
B captures on c3 now you get he captures
on b7 this is with check King captures
and now Queen to g4 check King to c7 and
now rook to d3 the threat now is rook
captures on c3 pinning the Queen and
winning it C capture some b2 now there
is no more rook to c3 but now comes a
rook to b3 as you can see now the King
is completely cut off from the B file
the Queen is slicing all the way here
the knight is ready to jump to e6 this
is a terrifying position for Poli
so let's say f5
making room for the knight on f6 Queen
captures Knight to f6 but now comes
Knight to e6 check King c6 and now rub
the b6 check King D 7 now roped a b7
check and if you play King back to c6
then you no longer have this battery and
the threat of capturing and c2 so you
have to move it and after Knight
captures on g7 King has to go to f8 and
now you push f e5 and this a 5 is the
breakthrough that white means and now
black is completely busted notice that
after playing a5 now the queen is also
protecting c2 so you don't gain anything
by exchanging Queens here after Queen
captures Queen captures and rook
captures you can simply give the King a
little check on e6 King Moo's and now
simply D captures on f6 Roxy 1 check
captures captures captures and after
Bishop captures simply g7 rook has to
move with check and now the bishop has
to capture the pawn on g7 as it's ready
to become a queen so Bishop captures
Knight captures and you're up to 2
pieces and you still have a pawn if this
is completely winning so this is this is
something that you will only see in
Rasheed's games another another
interesting point is that after this
sorry not here but after this oh man
there are so many variations after this
if I move you don't want to capture on
c2 what you want to play is be captures
on e5 but even still you're still lost
Knight captures on e6 Queen goes King
goes to 8 and now g7 rook moves and
Queen to g6 this is checkmate so not
something you want to do after g6 so f6
obviously doesn't work let's try the
other idea of B captures on c3 if B
captures on c3 then G captures on f7
would check if King captures it then of
course wing captures on g7 so King to d8
and now comes b3 first kicking the Queen
off of that important square
we have Queen to b4 and now comes earth
captures on e6 attacking both the bishop
on d7 and the night and g8 so knife to
f6 but now comes he captures on d7
attacking the rook Knight captures and
you don't want to capture with the night
because if you capture with the knight
then you get 290 to e6
and this is checkmate so definitely you
want to capture with the King and after
King captures you have a five again a
very important breakthrough pawn
captures and now this Knight to c6
opening up and attack to the King and
also attacking the Queen um before so
you lose the Queen and the game so what
else is there after g 6f 6 doesn't work
b captures and c3 doesn't work let's see
a 5v5 and d5 was played in the game by
polly after five first b 3 and this is
another crucial move this is again
something you will see in nature midi
knows games you're playing b3 and you're
forcing the Queen now to capture the the
knight on c3 as you don't want the Queen
to be protecting the f7 square so unless
you want to move the Queen you know just
waste a move you have to take it and now
comes to G captures on f7
again you don't want to capture the pawn
because then the Queen launches forward
King to d8 and now Queen captures on g7
here we have e captures on d4 and now
not capturing the rook not capturing the
night bringing out the Queen and not
playing c8 promoting to a queen but as
always a rush it measures Medina plays
the strongest move and he plays Bishop
captures on d4 and you'll see why this
is the strongest move Rashid saw this of
course he is inviting black to play
Queen captures and c2 and it's
interesting black really tried the
entire game just gained something here
on the this C file and now Rashid is
practically forcing him to capture on c2
but after this is done queen characters
into a1 black really doesn't have a way
of continuing this attack Polly finds
rook to h2
and he's very close if he can get one
move he will checkmate and is Medina of
here on a two but it's quite too late
for that
here night Medina plays Bishop to b6
check and this is why Bishop capture son
before was important to free this Bishop
on b6 check black has no moves the pawn
is guarding the a square you have to
block this if you block it with the
Queen well then of course everything is
said and done so after rook to c7 and
now comes again the strongest move and
that is Queen captures on g8 so the pawn
would be protecting d8 square here again
you don't really have anything it's
checkmate into whatever you play first
you have to give up one Bishop Queen
captures on f8 which check Bishop to e8
given up another Bishop and now you can
either play Queen captures or you can
bring another Queen into the game and
finish the game like this so we have
Queen captures promoting to a queen and
we have this again very nice chest
threesome as we've had in that McHale
tile game I've shown but after this the
game didn't continue this far poly
actually resigned after this Bishop to
b6 move as he saw that there is no point
in continuing this game this was just a
bonus variation I just got so so into
the game I forgot to mention this so
after Bishop e6 the game was resigned
but then the reason I just show you is
the reason why and reco poly resigned
the game so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and an interesting
thing about this game is that have
before before this game Rasheed Nash
medina of received news that his wife
just gave birth to their son
so after this game he sent a telegram to
his wife saying that he congratulate her
on the birth of their son
and that he also dedicates this
beautiful game against poli to the birth
of their son so yeah I do hope you
enjoyed it like I said he didn't win
first place he got half a point less
than Viktor Korchnoi but as Mike hotel
said the bro
supply price always went to Rashid Najma
Dean of so yeah and one thing I always
like to mention if you haven't if this
is maybe the first time you heard about
Rashid measurement Dean of do check out
Rashid Najma Dean of documentary by
Jessica Fischer on YouTube it's the most
amazing video on YouTube I've seen it
like like I don't know ten times maybe
and if you enjoyed this game by Rashid
nutriment you know to check it out and
after seeing that you will simply enjoy
all of his MIDI notes games so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank John Francois the
T thank you very much for a contribution
I really appreciate it sorry if I
pronounced it a bit wrong it's it's an
exotic name as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
probably with another great classic and
do check out the game in the description
bye Bronstein again Schneider
see you soon